[Music]
so you guys know i'm a pretty big uh
star wars fan big pretty big fan of star
wars all right is anybody else a big fan
of star wars i love that wars i love
star trek
they don't you don't even know what star
trek is yeah name it captain bro captain
uh pointy ears kirk jesus what's the
name of [ __ ] that's what's the name of
the ship the starship trooper
that's our usually
galactica or spock is what you're
thinking about or pron solo what's that
number one most famous quote from star
trek that everyone says chewbacca
i see what you're doing the number one
quote from star wars the star challenge
different star check it goes right here
it's right claiming to be a star trek
guy right yeah yeah do that and then say
the line yeah go ahead look at the
camera go ahead save the line
opposite opposite of death i've arrived
yep you got it
you got it guys how did he do it how do
you do it you've never seen one episode
what's the track then if all he says is
that he's right that's what he gets
there when he gets there he goes right
end of season one
it's always a new trek that's not every
season so you guys know that disney
disney bought star wars a couple years
ago right yes and then disney decided
they're like you know what we're gonna
do star wars land all right and they've
they called it batu i thought they
called it galaxy's edge the whole
galaxy's edge but this is this planet
called batu have you been i have been do
you like it
i think it sucks dick really why do you
what do you hate is that where you get
the blue drink you get the blue drink
yeah you get that place is cool man
pretty uh have you ever been yeah
okay you don't know what the [ __ ] star
wars is
but they got the uh the the [ __ ] what
is the starship troopers
what is that
storm group no the [ __ ] plane the
millennium falcon
x-wing you're talking about aluminum
falcons
the atlanta falcons are there
the elena you said the malena falcon the
millennial falcons no wonder people come
to life the wonder people tomorrow
falcons dude the melania millennium
falcon this show handles pop culture
like nothing else
all right all through parts i do think
galaxies that just type though so okay
we got two people let's talk about it
right so so and i'm not going to debate
you about it for me my my issue like
what you liked about it i assume was
just what they had there for me i was
like okay cool you get to finally go to
a place from star wars and see it in
real life but that's not
been any of the movies like there's no
boxing in any of the [ __ ] they just
made it up i see
something from the movies like you
literally put tattooing in every [ __ ]
movie give us that or something did you
well they they had the bar yeah but it's
not the bar though so would it be the
equivalent of so i i really like game of
thrones would it be like if they just
built a land that you didn't even see in
the show that's exactly right and that's
that's exactly what happened i see
that's the last season too how confusing
would be if harry potter land didn't
have hogwarts castle they're like it's
this other harry potter place
and you're like wait why
it's uh what's the big guy's uh what's
the name hagrid it's hagrid's house what
if it was haggar's house but haggar's
house has been in the movie yeah it's a
tree house
don't yell at me okay i can know my [ __ ]
i get your frustration it's like if they
made it you got served line and you
couldn't directly ride on omarion's wet
back from the rain
it's like if they made a honey to land
honey too
not one bro honey too or step up but but
they didn't put you know this dance
studio from the movie it was just some
other place it was a different dance
thank you thank you all right so so what
they've now done is they have released
the star wars land and you liked it
we'll talk about that later is it in
disneyland i like it too okay cool yeah
but what they have now done is released
this place called star wars galactic
star cruiser
which is a cruise
that doesn't [ __ ] go anywhere is
there like a cruise ship
it's a cruise
like in star wars land so you go to this
place you pay five jeeps
five g's two nights boys
and you don't [ __ ] go anywhere what
do you mean like is it like the queen
mary yeah you just stayed yeah it's like
a ship yeah that's parked yeah
you pay five g's you better get a
[ __ ] mickey blow job for that [ __ ]
you don't even get a mickey blow job
dude but does it not go anywhere in the
same way that like star tours doesn't
technically go into it but it feels like
you go somewhere yes not at five g's for
two nights though you ain't doing star
tours for two nights
can you imagine that we're gonna do star
tours
you get to stay in one of these rooms oh
that's cool by the way it looks like
star trek
in my opinion this doesn't really know
style that's pretty good what's that
logo what logo was that alan iverson
what
they could have done anything with they
could have done anything with this right
they could have
they could have made these big rooms
like more spacious rooms they decided to
make it look like a cruise ship which
this is not a cruise ship this is just a
hotel nothing on the disney property
nothing in here screen accurate to being
in the movie nah doesn't look good no
it's not it's not that because they have
like some stuff like some of the
lighting like some of the lighting stuff
yeah that wasn't particular to an exact
scene yeah no no that's kind of sad then
yeah it's like i like where is a saying
with hogwarts it's not like you're in
the [ __ ] castle in like where they
slept in the four you know post beds and
whatnot
it's like elements and stuff but it's
not quite one yeah i wanted a big poster
of the reading rainbow guy just hanging
out there i'd be sick right yeah so this
is like in your hotel room they have
this like little view screen reading but
but it's just like a tv but it's just a
tv screen with like projecting a space
image which could be cool but like you
know it's just one of those things where
it has to be really cool it has to be
super cool yeah why the [ __ ] would it be
five thousand dollars for two nights
okay so so we're talking about what what
what you get with this right
but not five g's
you show up you walk through this like
concrete um expanse right into a room
where you get shuttled to the hotel but
really they're just like decking up an
elevator to the hotel
and then but it looks like you're
traveling in space or whatever and then
you get there and then they assign you
with like a little watch that can i
watch right and then they're like our
apple watch and then basically um that's
what continue your rooms and that's what
also tracks your story progress oh cool
so this is like a role
oh it's like it's like westworld like a
role-playing event nice it's actually
getting kind of tired okay okay okay you
get a c3po [ __ ] am i right joe
we're good at popcorn oh yeah only some
of these guys suck all right how come
see how come i have arrived
[Laughter]
how come c-3po sounds like a gay british
man because he kind of is okay because
he learned english hey at least you know
that why'd you do the bit of a boob
because it's funny
it's funny okay so so when you get there
right you're checking your hotel room
and then you kind of talk to like this
little computer console or whatever and
you basically pick so it's like hey i
think i'm going to join the resistance
hey i think i'm going to join the bat
the bad guys hey i think i think i'm
going to join the force hey i think i'm
going to be a technician or some [ __ ]
which side chewbacca goes
[Music]
so
if you like once that happens all these
story elements start to happen on the
ship apparently okay and that includes
lightsaber training what you playing i'm
kind of in bro i'm kind of not for five
years
activity remember five grand wait i
thought this is star trek how come it's
star wars now this is star wars buddy
they they switch they switch it's star
wars the whole time
how come you guys opened it up with star
trek why don't you just talk about c-3p
if you didn't know
no but you told me star trek in the
beginning no he did it
i thought we were trolling the star wars
thing
it was actually the opposite so joe
doesn't pay attention and bart doesn't
know pop culture
[Laughter]
so they're they're shooting for sugar
yeah they're not committed look at them
yeah [ __ ] asses i don't want them on my
this is kind of a cool idea though it's
a cool idea maybe potentially but for
five g's for two nights you wouldn't do
it for five years you're expensive
that's not the point if we would do the
point is if somebody would do it
charge [ __ ] five g's would you go as
a influencer brand deal they were like
hey come just [ __ ] oh a thousand percent
i [ __ ] wear a mask
[Laughter]
mandates are done but steve was like nah
i'm gonna mandate myself would you would
you go to star trek outfit would you
wear a boba fett helmet i have a uh
i have a regrettable story about a
galaxy's edge yeah go ahead i hope i
didn't tell this already before did i
tell it i've never heard you even talk
about star wars yeah
all right uh so i uh
sounds really drunk
we should start there because that's
probably why i need to apologize right
away right you've been drinking there
i've been drinking i've been drinking
anyways
so you can drink that right and i got
drunk and uh i was i was with chad
brother and we go into uh riders of the
resistance which is this ride in the
galaxy's edge right and rise of the
resistance there is there it is and then
you go through the line and stuff like
that and before you actually get to the
ride there's like kind of the experience
of going through the line is its own
experience it's my first time ever being
on it by the way
and uh i didn't know
and i wasn't in tune and aware of
something i was also drunk that uh
because it was an imperial army type of
thing that the
staff was supposed to kind of like treat
everybody kind of like [ __ ] it's like
one of those things where they're like
uber mean to you
okay
i wasn't
disneyland is not that's not their thing
that's not their brand needs so you
thought they're disrespectful yeah yeah
so i thought it was really good but this
is how it came at me right you're so
drunk
one of uh my boy chad he had a uh uh
lacroix uh in his [ __ ] bag right and
he also had a pin that like stabbed him
because the back fell off he in the
beginning of the day it like fell off so
then it was like stabbing i was like
i'll put in your bag so he put in his
bag and he also had this lacquard right
and then in the line
the pin like punctured the lacrosse so
his bag started kind of dripping and
we're in this really thin like
there's only one way kind of lined right
so it starts dripping this [ __ ] like
you know soda water in the line and
stuff like that and it's really uh right
at the last part of the the line which
is this uh narrow corner at the
turnstile and by the time you like
figured it out we're like why you
leaking he pulls out his thing and then
it like spills all over so now there's a
giant water look lacroix water pile on
the floor and it's not something anybody
can just avoid because it's a very
narrow line
so i felt compelled to notify the staff
that we had spilled that and apologize
on it right again i'm junk still so i
let the lady know the turnstile as we're
going through the thing i was like hey
i'm really sorry uh we spilled some
water uh back there and it's kind of
just in the middle right
and her response to me
she like takes a second though i kind of
maybe she broke character for a second
so i didn't really know what's going on
either and then she takes a second as
i'm walking out she's like she said
something like um next time make sure
you don't spill stuff right and i was
that in character or was that out of
character did you sound that urban it
sounded yeah it just sounded really
off is all right and i got confused i
look back and there's an asian guy who's
behind me some other person who like
maybe like emphasizes like because it
got really awkward but i was like all
right cool whatever and i just kind of
let it pass but i was already kind of
like what the [ __ ]
and then the next part that's resort the
next part is you stand in this like
little line right before you go on the
ride right they have you like stand in
little like uh groups on this little
piece of tape on the floor or whatever
and then uh i'm just over there and i'm
trying to explain what happened and the
lady is pretty much telling us she
didn't say shut up but she's like if you
guys could please be quiet blah blah
stand in your line and don't move around
or whatever
what a great experience yeah and it got
really awkward because i feel like if i
was working and that was the concept i
would make sure that somebody understood
that was a concept for example like on
behalf of the imperial army you must you
know what i mean like you would use
content you mean be the character
exactly but she was just saying things
like don't make a noise make sure you
stand by
your insulin it wasn't even it really
wasn't character yeah and she's working
on it i got super petty just felt more
like six flags maybe she's just working
on it
i got super petty right and i i was
really immature again i was young i
don't know i i think i looked and
there's like kids over there and [ __ ]
and i look at him like i'm like ooh big
lady
is that cannon though testosterone
yeah so it was just really annoying for
me if i if it was if i recognized what i
was doing i i was an [ __ ] i would
totally apologize to that person now
yeah but going out of it i'm like why
did they not like acknowledge the thing
you're trying to tell them yeah or like
use the context of like you know what
i'm saying maybe they're winking at you
you didn't you didn't see it you're too
drunk you weren't drunk
she's like trying to tell you we'll take
care of it but stay in character so real
quickly the biggest thing going on with
this right so a bunch of tuber
influencers
got invited to this as like the first
group of people
and then of course they're all like
going like i'm [ __ ] coming like to
this to this experience right but then
their fans are watching the footage of
it being like this is not worth money i
can't believe you're trying to sell us
this [ __ ] so there's this not worth five
grand there's this thing going on we're
like you know for a lot of years the
review space on youtube has been
populated unfortunately with people who
get a lot of access
from a lot of these big companies who
are like yo we'll invite you to our
event for free you get to come and
they're not even into this [ __ ] to
create hype right yeah create the hype
love it
jerk off on it yeah so the hype is not
great and the reactions are not good
because most fans are watching this
going this is cringy [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
is this and 5 g's is pretty [ __ ]
expensive
because you know
the star wars world has a lot of really
rich old geeks and they'll do it yeah
the 40 plus year old dudes that like
grew up doing this [ __ ] that are like
tech millionaires they're the ones that
are going to pay for it not like the 12
year olds
yeah their parents 13 year olds maybe
steve as a as an avid star wars fan
out of the most recent star wars stuff
that they've done like what has been
your most favorite uh star wars project
star wars one
like recent like with disney with the
the with disney yeah i mean you know
mando i haven't watched mando i haven't
watched amanda oh really maybe yoda i
need to watch it look star wars star
wars spurned me so bad with the new ones
i went to the force awakens midnight
like i was dude
i got disney to get me into like the
[ __ ] premiere because i was part of
maker studios at the time and i was like
you get me the [ __ ]
i bled for this place
they got me nice and i hated the [ __ ]
movie yeah i hated it and i saw it with
everybody i thought was like [ __ ]
harrison ford and [ __ ] like it was like
that yeah it was wild did a lot of
people hate it did you look at them and
say i'm so disappointed in you no i
walked out actually and i'm i'm not so
oh wow you walked out no i don't know i
walked out at the end when i was over
and i because i was so excited for this
you guys think i was like [ __ ] so
excited for this i walk out and jj
abrams is as close to me as bart is
right now and i just look at him like
this
i'm not kidding i swear to god in my
life may god strike me dead because
you're like you [ __ ] at all i just
couldn't believe that it was that he
didn't say star trek was better he said
i am leaving
if you knew star trek you would know he
also did star trek and that's why it was
better okay that's why i said that yeah
because i watched all this [ __ ] nice
i'm not a fan of the way that they just
they just get rid of all the stuff that
made everyone love star wars and then
just do all this new stuff and go
everyone clearly loves all this the most
and i'm like they kept making [ __ ] up
was that when you unanimously located by
most star wars no no i don't think it's
like that i think the force awakens was
generally like everyone thought it was
okay like or like even good the best
movie that came out out of the new ones
was rogue one besides
yeah i agree with that
the last jedi was dick they kept making
up the the the [ __ ] telepathic
talking and i was like since when can
jedi's do this and i turned it off well
between ray and adam drivers i was like
what is this what is this they could do
that in the originals actually as soon
as they brought an asian cast member i
said [ __ ] this i'm not supporting it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you